MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR STARTING OFF THE
SHOW.
YOU HAVE HEARD THAT THE
MUELLER REPORT ARRIVED WITH NO
FURTHER INDICTMENTS ACCORDING
TO A SENIOR OFFICIAL.
THAT IS IT.
NO ONE ELSE WILL BE INDICTED
FOR COLLUSION OR IN ADDITION
ADDITION -- IN ADDITION ELSE.
SO NOT A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL
CHARGED WITH ANYTHING RELATED
TO RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
NOT ROGER STONE OR PAUL
MANAFORT OR CARTER PAGE AND
NOT TRUMP.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE HAVE HAD
LIVES RUINED BY THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
SOME COULD DIE IN PRISON.
NOT ONE OF THEM COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA.
THE PEOPLE ON TV HAVE BEEN
LYING TO YOU.
THEY WILL DENY IT NOW.
THEY WILL TELL YOU IT WAS
ALWAYS ABOUT TRUMP'S TAXES OR
SOME FOREIGN REAL ESTATE DEAL
OR HUSH MONEY HE PAID TO A
GIRLFRIEND.
THAT IS A CROCK.
THIS INVESTIGATION WAS ALWAYS
FROM DAY ONE ABOUT COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA.
ABOUT BETRAYING THIS COUNTRY.
THEY TOLD US THAT FOR YEARS.
AND WE HAVE THE TAPE.
>> WHAT MAKES YOU BELIEVE THAT
HE HAS MORE INDICTMENTS?
>> BECAUSE HE HASN'T ADDRESSED
THE ISSUES RELATED TO CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY AS WELL AS ANY
INDIVIDUAL --
>> CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY
INVOLVING THE RUSSIANS?
>> YES.
>> IS -- THAT IS AN AREA YOU
KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT.
IT WAS DEVELOPING WHILE YOU
WERE ON THE JOB.
>> IT WAS IN TERMS OF LOOKING
AT WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THE
RUSSIANS AND WHETHER OR NOT
U.S. PERSONS WERE ACTIVELY
COLLABORATING, COLLUDING,
COOPERATING AND INVOLVED A
CONSPIRACY WITH THEM OR NOT.
BUT ALSO IF THERE IS GOING TO
BE ANY MEMBER OF --
>> DID YOU SEE ENOUGH AT THAT
STAGE TO BELIEVE THAT WOULD
RESULT IN INDICTMENTS ONCE
INVESTIGATED?
>> I THOUGHT AT THE TIME THERE
WAS GOING TO BE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE GOING TO HAVE ISSUES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: SO THAT WAS THE
FORMER C.I.A. DIRECTOR.
ONE OF COUNTLESS RETIRED INTEL
OFFICIALS YOU SEE PARADING
ACROSS YOUR SCREEN EVERY
NIGHT.
ALL OF THEM PAID BY THE MSNBC
OR CNN TO TOW THE PARTY LINE.
ALL OF THEM KNOW BETTER.
THEY ARE LYING.
A HABIT MANY PICKED UP YEARS
AGO.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS DID THE
SAME.
PICK ONE AMONG A THOUSAND
EXAMPLES THIS IS TENNESSEE
STEVE COHEN TELLING US MOST OF
THE TRUMP FAMILY IS BOUND FOR
PRISON.
>> WELL, I THINK THEY ARE
GETTING CLOSER KNOWING THAT
THE TRUTH IS GOING TO COME OUT
AND THAT THERE WAS ACTIVITIES
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIA AND RELEASING THE HACKS
AND GUIDING THEM TO THE STATES
AND LOCALITIES WHERE THEY CAME
FROM.
SOME OF THAT WAS JARED
KUSHNER'S RESPONSIBILITIES.
SOME OF IT WAS DONALD JR.
I THINK YOU WILL PROBABLY SEE
INDICTMENTS OF BOTH OF THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THAT MAN IS A
SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
HE IS WEARING NECKTIE.
HE IS ON TELEVISION.
PEOPLE BELIEVED HIM.
WHY WOULD THEY?
HE IS AN AUTHORITY FIGURE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND HE WAS LYING.
SO WAS SENATOR RICHARD
BLUMENTHAL WHO HAS SPENT YEARS
BRINGING SHAME TO THE STATE OF
CONNECTICUT AND HE EMBARRASSED
HIMSELF FURTHER ON MOCK
CERTAINTY ON THIS AND MANY,
MANY OTHER OCCASIONS.
>> THERE ARE INDICTMENTS IN
THIS PRESIDENT'S FUTURE.
THEY'RE COMING.
WHETHER THEY ARE AFTER HIS
PRESIDENCY OR DURING IT,
OBVIOUSLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SAID CANNOT INDICT A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, THERE
WAS HOWARD DEAN THE FORMER
GOVERNOR OF VERMONT.
DEAN WAS ALSO IF YOU REMEMBER
THAT FAR BACK TO 2004 A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
AT ONE POINT IT LOOKED LIKE HE
WOULD BE THE NOMINEE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE WENT ON TO RUN THE D.N.C.
HE IS ON TELEVISION
CONSTANTLY.
PEOPLE LONG WHISPERED THAT
HOWARD DEAN IS NOT ALL THERE.
THEY SAY HE YELLS SO MUCH
BECAUSE HE CAN'T THINK WELL.
HE IS SO SLOW IT TAKES HIM
HOUR AND A HALF TO WATCH "60
MINUTES."
YOU DON'T WANT TO BELIEVE IT'S
TRUE.
IT SOUNDS CRUEL.
BUT THEY MIGHT BE RIGHT.
>> WE BELIEVE WE MAY HAVE A
CRIMINAL IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE NEXT STEP IS THE TRUMP
FAMILY ITSELF.
I EXPECT THERE IS A GOOD
LIKELIHOOD THAT JARED KUSHNER
WILL BE INDICTED FOR MONEY
LAUNDERING AND THEN WE HAVE TO
SEE HOW FAR THE RUSSIAN
INVOLVEMENT GOES.
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS.
THE PEOPLE ARE UNDERMINING OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: IT WAS NEVER
SERIOUS BUSINESS.
ANOTHER LIE.
IT WAS LUDICROUS.
IT WAS ALWAYS LUDICROUS.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH EVIDENCE
YOU MUSTER YOU WILL NEVER
CONVINCE STALLWELL OF THAT.
THE ORIGINAL COLLUSION
TRUTHER.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF THE
RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY THAT
STALLWELL -- BEEN ON THE SHOW
MANY TIMES -- ISN'T EAGER TO
BELIEVE AND MAGNIFY.
HE SHOULD HAVE AN OVERNIGHT
SHOW ON A.M. RADIO AND TELL US
HOW PUTIN RUNS BILDERBERG.
CNN, OF COURSE, LOVES ERIC
SWALWELL.
FOR YEARS THEY BROADCAST
UNCRITICALLY EVERY LUNATIC
CLAIM THAT SWALWELL EVER MADE.
HERE IS ONE EXAMPLE.
>> IT'S LOOKING MORE AND MORE,
WOLF, THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS A
PART OF A CRIMINAL CAMPAIGN,
CRIMINAL TRANSITION AND NOW
PRESIDES OVER A CRIMINAL
PRESIDENCY.
>> Tucker: A CRIMINAL
WHAT IS CRIMINAL IS WHAT JUST
HAPPENED.
WE HAVE LIVED THROUGH THREE
SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS IN TO
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
NOT JUST MUELLER.
BUT COMMITTEE IN THE HOUSE AND
A COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE.
THEY SPENT YEARS LOOKING IN
THIS.
IN THE END, THEY FOUND
NOTHING.
BUT DURING THAT TIME THIS
COUNTRY, THE COUNTRY THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE RUNNING HAS
BECOME OBVIOUSLY AND
MEASURABLY WORSE.
SUICIDE, DRUG O.D.s ARE UP.
LIFE EXPECTANCY IS FALLING.
THE BORDERS ARE A MESS.
WE HAVE NO CLUE WHO LIVES IN
THIS COUNTRY.
TO THE TUNE OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
MAYBE TENS OF MILLIONS.
NO IDEA.
THE SCHOOLS ARE A JOKE.
YOU WOULDN'T SEND YOUR KIDS TO
THEM IF YOU HAD A CHOICE.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRUMBLING.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS SLEEP OUTSIDE EVERY
NIGHT.
WHAT ARE THE LEADERS TALKING
ABOUT?
WHAT DO THEY SPEND TIME
OBSESSING OVER?
WHAT DO THEY GET TV BOOKINGS
TO RANT ABOUT?
IRRELEVANT MEETING WITH A
MINOR RUSSIAN LAWYER IN TRUMP
TOWER THREE YEARS AGO.
THE NEW YORK CITY SUBWAY
BARELY WORKS.
THE LARGEST CITY IN THE UNITED
STATES SMELLS LIKE GARBAGE.
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING IT.
WHAT DOES BILL DE BLASIO, THE
MAYOR, TALK ABOUT?
HE IS RANTING ABOUT PUTIN.
THIS HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
HOW CAN WE LET PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT CONTINUE AS
IF IT NEVER HAPPENED?
HOW CAN ERIC SWALWELL AND ADAM
SCHIFF KEEP THEIR SEATS IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES?
THEY SHOULD RESIGN.
HOW CAN JEFF ZUCKER REMAIN AT
CNN AFTER WE NOW KNOW MUCH OF
WHAT HIS NETWORK TOLD US FOR
TWO YEARS IS A TOTAL LIE?
IT IS A TOTAL LIE.
WHAT ABOUT THE VICTIMS OF THIS
MONSTROSITY?
THERE ARE MANY.
ROGER STONE IS FACING LIFE IN
PRISON.
HE WAS INDICTED BY AN
INVESTIGATION DESEINED TO FIND
COLLUSION -- DESIGNED TO FIND
COLLUSION.
MINOR CHARGES.
DRAGGED FROM HIS OWN HOME IN A
MORNING F.B.I. RAID.
THEY PUT AN AMPHIBIOUS VEHICLE
OUTSIDE HIS HOUSE AND POINTED
AN AUTOMATIC WEAPON IN HIS
FACE TO FIND COLLUSION.
BUT THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
STONE IS STILL LOOKING AT LIFE
IN PRISON.
WHERE IS ROGER STONE'S PARDON?
HIS PARDON FROM THE PRESIDENT?
LET'S HOPE IT COMES VERY SOON.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION IS